all right well thank you everyone for
having me here with you today uh today
we're going to talk about the skin
microbiome current perspectives the
pitfalls and opportunities that we have
in this space I already was introduced
it's very nice to meet you all just to
give you a little bit about my
background you know my PhD is in
immunology and microbial pathogenesis so
you know I'm going to bring forth that
perspective of both the microorganisms
but the immunology and the aspects of
the environment in which those microbes
live as well
so first let's talk a little bit about
let me put this out
let's talk a little bit about
oops what the microbiome is
I need to sorry just one second
okay here we are so what is the
microbiome so the microbiome it needs to
be differentiated from what the
microbiota is a lot of people in this
field use the term microbiome to mean
the bacteria of fungi or organisms that
exist in an environment but really what
the definition means is a combination of
the microbiota which are again those
bacteria archaea fungi viruses Etc and
the activity that they produce in the
environment so the proteins and peptides
lipids polysaccharides other things that
they produce in that environment and the
environment itself because these you
know where they live so we're talking
about the skin here today so the
environment would be the human skin the
human skin brings its own unique
environmental aspects and so that
dictates often the microbes that can
live in in that particular niche of the
skin and I'll share more details about
that as we go forward but also the
organisms themselves are producing
compounds and metabolites and those then
also influence that environment both the
other microbes in the in the environment
itself and the skin in this case the
environment I'm talking about itself
that is really what the microbiome
definition means and as we continue to
evolve in this field I think it's really
important that we all understand that it
encompasses both the microbes and the
environment and their function
altogether
the other interesting and important
aspect to consider here is you know the
fact that we now really consider
ourselves or view ourselves in the field
as a hollow biome and what do I mean by
that that means that we as humans human
beings have our own host genome we have
the genes that influence our biology and
our structure and function but we
understand now I think more than ever
that we're colonized both within and on
our bodies with these microorganisms
that bring their own genome to this
um this consorture this collaboration
and that together is is what we're
talking about when we say the holobion
the the microorganisms and ourselves and
all the interactions that those genes
and influences have together and then we
have of course the environment in which
we live that also dictates how that
holobions exists in in the in the
environment they're in so if you live in
a very moist rainy hydrated environment
versus living in the desert the
organisms and the environment that you
reside in is going to info influence
some of the interactions in the
organisms that you might be associated
with as well so it's important to have
this perspective as we talk about the
skin because we're going to talk about
it in a holistic way meaning both us as
human beings and the organisms that live
on that skin itself
so first let's talk about the microbiota
in the context of the skin microbiome so
on the skin which I'll explain in more
detail more about the structured
function in a few slides what we have
what we Now understand really is that we
have a balanced microbiome on the skin
of of our of our of our human body and
it's a habitat of billions of beneficial
and potentially harmful bacteria that
all exist in this balance in a state of
health and an imbalance of these
organisms or an imbalance in the
environment I.E the skin can lead to a
variety of conditions like acne eczema
rosacea and even aging as we start to
understand
so on the skin the microbiome or the
microbiota that live there they really
prefer an acidic environment your skin
has a pH of around anywhere from four to
five and a half and this pH is driven
largely through you know the the
production of acid compounds on your
Skin's surface and the microbes also
contribute to that reduction of pH on
your skin and this is why you hear a lot
about pH balance and maintaining a pH
balance what we mean by that is keeping
the pH in an acidic State because that's
what's healthiest for your skin and
healthiest for the commensal organisms
that have evolved to live with and on
you
and the diversity of this microbiome
differs depending on where you're
looking on the skin so as you all know
because we all have skin the skin is
different in different parts of our body
the skin on the the face is different
than the skin in the lower leg versus
the hand for example and these
differences in the temperature the
texture thickness humidity and even the
chemistry of what's produced on that
surface of the skin help determine what
microbes get to live there